All right.
Benny Czarny, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Michael, thanks for having me.
Benny, I just want to hear
about your journey.
It's very rare to meet a founder
that bootstrapped a company
from their living room as an engineer
and grew it to over a thousand customers.
Some of the most notable companies
that we all know here in the US.
But more importantly,
you're providing cyber security systems
for 98% of the US nuclear facilities.
Is that right?
That's correct. Let me just address
just one example.
So, our mission is to protect
critical infrastructure.
I mean, yes, nuclear facility
is one of that.
That's what, one testimony
of our success.
However, we do everything.
We do government.
we do [--], agriculture
utilities, other energies.
It's not only nuclear,
there is also renewable.
There is solar. There is tons.
Benny, I'm starting
with the most important question.
Do you sleep at night?
I mean, seriously, aren't you scared
about what you're doing?
This is crazy.
Yeah. I sleep really well.
There would be rare occasions
that I don't sleep well at night.
I like to sleep well at night.
Wonderful.
Okay, Benny, take me back.
Take me back
to the founding days of OPSWAT.
How does it start?
And what is your strategy
in building this company,
which now is huge huge success?
Great. Thank you.
So, how it started?
So, it all started with an idea, a vision.
Everything starts there.
So, also talk to your other person.
What do you want to do?
So, you want to go,
I mean, I knew, I think actually,
if you ask me when I was I think
it was sixth grade,
what do you gonna do?
I would tell you, I'm gonna go on
and build a cyber security company.
When I was six, I went and it was funny.
[--] a childhood friend
[--]
Still happening by the way.
He also, he founded in,
then founding another company
in civil engineering
and we're still having that today.
Amazing.
Our wives are laughing at us.
Amazing. Okay.
So, you have this vision.
You have the strategy.
You're gonna build
a cyber security company.
But you do it in a very unorthodox way
because today it's diverse.
Every engineer out of 8200
wants to build a cyber security company,
raises a ten million dollars seed,
goes to series A
and sells it for $200 million.
You did something else?
Yeah. So, what I did,
I bootstrapped it.
So, I start with first the goal.
What was the global mission?
I said, "Hey, what can I do?"
Okay, let's see, what do I have here?
And when I started the company,
it was 2002.
I view, okay fine, I've got to go
and put something together.
I'm gonna go in and do it.
And I'm going to make it.
Could I raise money in 2002?
Yes, I could.
If I wanted to, I would focus on that.
I found myself much more battling between
selling the products to customers
willing to or ready to use the product
and appreciate it,
to spending my time
actually talking to the investors.
And then at some point I said,
"You know what?"
"I'm gonna go and try taking the hard way
and then go all the way
without anything else."
It's not like a invested capital.
So, initially, what I did,
I provide some professional services,
not in that area, in other.
And I use that fund
or professional services
to hire engineers
to go and build the product.
I start eventually with one.
After that one became two,
two became four,
four became eight, and so on and so on.
Wow. So, there is no institutional funding
throughout the lifetime of OPSWAT?
No, not yet, no.
Unbelievable. Okay.
Now, talk to me a little bit
about about the journey.
So, now you have
over a thousand customers.
You are handling over 98%
of the nuclear facilities in the US.
How do you get to a level
where you're building the trust
where the US government
is letting you defend
its most critical infrastructure?
I mean, to me that sounds like
the highest level you can get to
as a cybersecurity company.
And so, it's all depends,
that might be operating principles.
Well, number one is the technology.
Be committed to the technology.
Yeah. I would hope so.
Number two is very much
the people on the team.
It's all about the people.
The companies for me, is the team.
It's everything about the team
that is being built.
Their motivation, their aspiration.
What do they do.
Whatever their kind.
Whatever we think.
Wherever they go.
And what keeps them up is
how to make sure
the product is competitive.
The product  is doing
what it's supposed to do.
We are very transparent about the product.
How? From end to end.
From marketing through
how the product is operating.
Three, we go to market.
The channel.
The how we go,
and very much selling the product.
They're out there.
How we reached out to these folks
of their needs.
Right. So, how many people are involved
in this right now, with OPSWAT?
The company we are over
321 employees today.
Incredible.
And growing.
Actually we have 30 open positions.
Despite the corona we are hiring.
30 open positions?
Yes.
So, you're looking to grow 10%
during covid-19?
Yes, we are. Yes, we are.
We are not, I mean, critically,
I'm talking to our customers.
I'm talking to customers in anywhere.
They are going to the office.
So, [--]
Most of our customers,
we still have some customers
end of the day.
We are building a great product.
We have some awesome nontraditional,
critical infrastructure companies
buying our solutions.
So, they are not bank.
They are not energy, not utility.
Not to brag
because we have a good product.
Over most of our customers
are going to the office.
Incredible. Okay.
So, you know, I have quite a few friends
who have either lost their internship
or lost their job offer because things
have gone awry.
So, definitely, this sounds great.
But Benny, talk to me a little bit
about the cyber security space.
I want your earned secrets
over these years of building OPSWAT.
You're dealing with some of the most
incredible companies.
And you really are an expert
in the cyber security field
simply because you've been
selling in the field
and you've been developing
a cutting edge technology there.
What is the cybersecurity space today
like in the world?
And what are the biggest challenges
that we're heading towards?
If you're looking at the cybersecurity
from that perspective,
it's very segregated.
I mean, if I'm looking at company,
very segregate.
I see very very good companies all over
sometimes doing just one point solution.
That created very good e-mail security.
Create a really good antivirus
or a different point solution.
And if you're looking at the cyber map
you see more than 3,000
cybersecurity companies out there.
Maybe 500 are in Israel.
And then you're like, so.
And you see that.
So, what is missing from that perspective?
So, what's unique about us is very much
a critical infrastructure protection.
So, holistic view
on critical infrastructure.
We have two platforms that helps you
not only prevent spreads,
also create a process.
So, whenever we research
cyber security attacks, it's all about,
not only about defending,
it's also creating a process.
We go to CEOs, to IT managers.
We asked them,
"Who is bringing data?"
"Who is bringing devices?"
"What type of data?"
"Do you have a policy?"
You'll be surprised
that there is no single answer.
We are there to go and solve this problem.
Another operating principle
that I've seen is that,
there is not enough education system.
So, there is no training.
There is no official training.
There could be a training for a product.
Though there is no training
for the problem
and what you're trying to achieve.
So, on that also,
you look for example, investing,
[--]
So, it's all about training the IT folks
for the critical infrastructure.
Now, I don't promote it to be here
just to promote, use that amazing stand
just to promote the company,
though, you asked me about how I see
the cyber security market.
So, I find very segregated,
very points focused,
very product focused.
not so much solutions for problems.
Obviously, you have the big folks.
You have the checkpoint of the world,
the Palo Alto of the world here.
The sister of the world, and you say,
"Oh, we do everything in cybersecurity."
So, this is more than the military.
You need cyber security,
you get the military.
And then you have the point solution
That is more of the products folks.
That's something that companies
doing something specific,
something is very good,
or a  one thing or sometimes two things
that they are repeating
and getting in the cybersecurity field.
Benny, it sounds to me, I'm coming
from the cyber security space myself.
But one of the things
that I learned quickly in my time in 8200
is that this world is changing constantly.
It's a cat and mouse game.
And new things are coming up all the time.
New technologies for every new device
that today, our fans are connected.
And I believe that one of them,
really mind changing moments that I had
was back in my course in the Army.
And we had a guest speaker who came in
and showed us a paper
that they wrote in the Technion,
of how a ceiling fan
can actually transmit data
that you wouldn't expect it to.
And I was thinking to myself,
a ceiling fan can give me information,
the critical information about,
about whatever is happening.
And I thought that was crazy.
So, how do you manage that new knowledge
that is constantly being creating?
Because, you're only relevant
as long as you're up to date
with what's happening.
You have to be ahead
of everybody else in the game, right?
So, that's a good one.
So, for that, we keep innovating.
So, to a point that
we keep having new product.
So, by the way, during the covid-19,
we released three new products.
So, to the point that, we are doing it.
So, I completely agree with you.
It's keep changing.
The threats landscape keep changing.
Though there's something else interesting.
I've seen in cyber security,
sometimes is revolving.
So, what you've seen that,
something that what's happening
10 years ago
is coming back to light sometimes.
And I think for example,
data loss prevention
on some other technologies
that are keeping reinventing themselves.
And the reason for that is that
the IT is changing.
And then security needs to catch up
with the new IT threat.
So, for example,
mobile phone, for example,
IT devices, [--]
So, the reason for that is
lies to what we do,
how we interact.
Work from home, for example,
is a different attack vector
for both productivity and security.
Of course.
So, that's it.
And now with covid that will accelerate
activities and productivities.
[--]
Interesting. Okay.
And how do you create a culture, though,
where people are interested in learning?
So, instead of just continuing to develop
the current software,
they're continuing to research
and understand what else is happening.
Do you deploy that through
a specific division that is responsible
for new key findings
or for learning, or do you collaborate
with academia and universities to see
what they're coming up with.
How do you maintain
the number one in the game?
Okay. So, there are
multiple answers for it.
Number one is our customer landscape.
We have so many deployments
that takes over 1500 customers,
to be precise.
So, we have lots of customers
and also products out there.
Every customer
deploy our product in multiple.
Our products, some of them has,
I mean, you can enable sensors
to go and understand
what's happening there.
And the customers,
if they like to share the threats with us,
we get a lot of data from
first our customers
and they see what was it.
Number two, we have our own
big data analysis.
So, big data analysis
we have data from the cloud
you can go and share data there.
And from the cloud
we have tons of users.
We have a whole community
of voters there just talking about.
Number three,
we have a model sharing program
with very much almost
every antivirus out there.
So, enable for example,
a vendor hired or sent you online
a Symantec, McAfee,
all of these products finding a threat.
We are oblige to go and share
threats with each other.
So, we research that.
And I think they're seeing, by the way,
in the cyber that is related to that
is that they also related
to the philosophy.
And also, if you talk about our success,
it's our technology philosophies
surely zero threats.
So, we assume all of the files are bad.
And so, we generate them.
So, another kind of operating philosophy.
And we tested moving landscape
on the moving targets
and the moving threats
[--]
I love it.
Benny, I wanna move a little bit
to the entrepreneurial journey
and leadership.
And I'd love to know,
the traditional path that I see here
is in the Valley and Tel Aviv is that,
you go, you raise institutional funding
and you move quickly.
And when you get to
ring the bell at NASDAQ,
like lemonade is doing today,
even though this is going to be shown
to the public later on.
But today, the lemonade is going public.
That's sort of the lifetime dream
of any entrepreneur.
It doesn't seem like that is necessarily
your ambition and your dream.
What is your consideration
for keeping the company private
rather than public?
And do you ever see yourself
going on to something else?
So, back to your question, actually,
now, there is a chance
We're going to public.
The order has gotten bigger.
A big O could be a big exits, too.
Could be a big merger with something over.
I don't operate this by, first,
I build the company to last.
I build the company last
with the good culture
with a good team,
with management team,
with a good business.
And that's kind of,
Where I get.
What's even for the employees?
Everything.
First, the equity that I provide
to the team members
is much better than diluting it
with some VC folks right now.
[--]
And whenever I keep asking.
I don't look
at the quantity of the stocks.
Look at their value,
for bringing in the case of an exit.
Right.
So, I have team members with stock
or stock options
depends on their situation in that.
And I believe that at some point,
we go further.
We decide to go to that [--] route,
or we decide to get to the bottom
with the private equity
to go and get it, which is another option.
I build the company to last.
I think, I mean,
that's the most inspiring part.
You building the company to last.
I think right now,
especially what I'm saying
with a lot of my colleagues
in my age group is that
you're not thinking about a company
that you're gonna be involved
with for 10, 15, 20 years.
You think about products
that you're gonna be excited to work on
for a year or two
and then sell or move on
to your next projects,
which is a very different mindset.
Benny, you moved from managing
one person, yourself basically
to now managing over 300 people
in this great company.
What have you learned over the years?
What surprised you
over things that you didn't expect?
It's covid.
Initially, I was very much of everything.
I was the big old guy.
I was the coder.
I was pretty much the HR,
the everything around it.
And then starting to get
a management team,
a professional management team in place.
The right system in place.
The banking systems in place
to go and put it together
to a point that it's,
and I see this journey
that been challenging me from, okay,
from doing work and it's actually changing
my kind of my day to day.
And I find it very fascinating.
I love it.
So, I find myself as, building careers.
And building careers inside the company.
I taught my executive these two things.
You have two honorable ways
to gonna leave the company.
Two honorable ways.
Option one, you die.
It's honorable, right?
Option number two,
go find your own company.
Right.
And by the way,
it worked with two executives.
Two past executives.
I mean, they didn't die.
They opened their own company.
Amazing. Successful?
[--]
They come over here.
We walk together as a team.
And after that, build your experience.
Then after five years,
they went, they build their own company.
I'm still in touch with them. Great.
This is what I call honorable way.
I love it.
Benny, what would be
the most important thing for you,
that if I would ask
any of your 300 employees,
I tell them, tell me one,
the best thing about Benny.
What would they tell me
about your leadership style?
Because I'm getting information
for myself.
I wanna be an entrepreneur myself one day
or continue being an entrepreneur
and create my own company.
And I'm thinking,
what are the most important traits
that I need to maintain
or uphold as a leader?
All right. So, I'm personable.
So,  with whatever I connect,
I'm connecting with you.
Talk to me.
So, I'm very personable.
I'm very direct too.
I say, "Hey, I hate it. I like you."
I think you're not gonna it.
And I think that when you match that
with the personable, then,
they don't take it personally
because  you care for them.
It's the feedback you're giving them
is not against them.
It's perhaps critical,
it's perhaps criticism over the work.
But because you build this personal trust,
then it's much more meaningful
to be direct, right?
Yeah.
So, that's on this one.
I'm direct and so on.
And then, I like to start to ask,
Why? What's in it for you?
So, connect to that point.
Also, I like to understand
what they like to do,
what they don't like to do.
People, usually they are good.
Usually, not always.
They are good at what they like to do.
Right.
So, that's kind.
And they like to take jobs
I think that they're good at.
And I'm trying to just ensure it's there
and to provide.
I have managers that have been with me
for many years in the Silicon Valley,
which is tough.
They manage with me for 12 years.
And there is one excuse,
gonna go and retire.
An executive gonna retire
from the company.
I see it all this,
I look at it as an accomplishment.
Incredible. I mean, I think it's amazing
that you're looking at that
as a source of accomplishment
for the company.
I don't think that
many founders and leaders would see that
as such a great accomplishment.
Obviously it is.
But I think just their focus
maybe on other things.
But it sounds like
you're putting the team first,
which I think is so so cool.
What is it about, though,
the culture that's making them want
to stay for so long?
Because opportunities here are endless.
There's constant competition
for the best talent, especially coming out
of the other great company like yours.
So, what do you think makes people
want to remain strong within
a company that like OPSWAT?
So, number one is our mission, right?
You want to be identify yourself
with the mission of the company.
It  really helps somebody, right?
So, we're not gonna go
Again, there are some people,
if you're not selling,
if you don't do something,
you're doing good,
you're not doing something bad.
Perceived to be bad by some.
So, there is very pure mission.
Number two, the commitment of the company
to the technology and the product,
something that is thriving with people.
Yes, we want to create a great product.
What I want the guy to,
if there's something bothering them,
like what, how,
what can be the customer experience.
Definitely.
End of the day, I would like
the team members
to think about the company.
And people like that
that they're connecting too.
Right.
They are very transparent culture.
So, the team members, they know.
Okay, we're making numbers.
What's there.
We usually make the numbers
and then we usually exceed them.
So, it's very transparent.
And also it's also keeping
a message of success.
No. I think that is support.
Which also tells
about a lot of predictions.
So, whenever we're operating a forecast,
not only to ourselves,
also to our vendors.
And also, internally,
to sales team members,
and to product managers
who like to be very honest
with the numbers.
And then also to  ourself,
and they're transparent to ourself.
And then if you can put together
a forecast, don't put it there.
Right. That I think something is that,
a lot of young entrepreneurs
need to uphold that and learn,
especially in today's age.
Benny, before we leave
20 minutes go by so fast.
I wanna thank you for your time
and your generosity.
We know each other from J-Ventures.
And it's been great working over there.
And we met in person
right before the start of Corona.
And I look forward
to seeing you again in person
in the monthly meetings after Corona.
But before we leave,
I need three words
that best describe you.
Oh.
The hardest question.
And you asking me to describe myself.
Usually, I'm gonna answer,
"Hey, go ask others
what they say about me."
So, you know what?
I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna ask,
If I were to ask any of your 300 employees
or your 1500 customers, who is Benny?
What are the three characteristics
that he is most represented as?
So he's a,
definitely a Builder.
Builder of technology and an innovator.
So, definitely I would say that
I'm very much kind of innovated platform
that it's not like another category
out there in the market,
that is successful and working.
A career builder.
So, building careers and then,
and also, career builder as well.
I would say that it would,
I think I can stand behind that.
It definitely sounds like it.
The third one, ouch,
I think that it's amazing
that you're thinking
critically about this.
Because a lot of people,
they know immediately
and they're saying,
like these interview questions.
But I think that you're so humble
and you're really, you're thinking about
the people that you have
and your building this
great great company.
And it exudes from this conversation
how you're putting so much focus
on the career building
and the success of your customers
and the success of others along with you.
You're not just thinking about
how can I make it the biggest,
but how can I build a culture
and how can I build a team
that is really proud of what we're doing.
And I think that speaks for itself.
So, I'm gonna be great with two words
with that description at the end.
So, I really wanna thank you
for this inspiration, really.
Thank you, Michael for the opportunity
to speak here.
I appreciate your time.
Of course. No, thank you.
And I'm gonna reach back to you.
Of course, when I have my own venture
and I can't wait to work together
in the future.
I'm looking forward to it. Take care.
Bye Benny. Toda  raba.